Церква святої Катерини у центрі Брюсселя.
Її вже кілька разів закривали і навіть мало не знесли –
стіни церкви розсипаються,
парафіян стало менше.
Та все змінилось,  коли прийшов молодий священик
ЖеремІ Шауб з чудовою ідеєю -
зробити сучасне церковне пиво для церкви, парафіян та всього району.
Варять пиво у приватній броварні неподалік.
Спершу, коли я тільки прийшов з цією ідеєю, вони були дещо здивовані.
Я теж був трохи збентежений, тому що це все було незвично.
Але я сказав собі,
що я маю набратись сміливості і зробити це.
Таким чином у співпраці з брюссельским стартапом-броварнею
з’явилось крафтове пиво "Санкт Кат",
назване на честь церкви.
За спільним рецептом команда
вже зварила сімнадцять тисяч літрів пива.
Ми спробували багато пива, щоб зрозуміти, що ми можемо робити
і що можемо винайти,
а тоді дійшли висновку, що маємо залишити в пиві бельгійський смак,
але і додати нову техніку, нові інгредієнтів,  незвичні для бельгійців.
У цьому казані вже вариться нова партія пива.
Його швидко розпродають.
Залишилось лише трохи більше шестисот пляшок.
Співпраця церкви і броварні виявилась дуже плідною.
Я вважаю, що це геніально,
адже таке незвичне поєднання двох світів виявилося дуже вдалим.
Це геніально готувати сучасне пиво з зображенням церкви.
Це демонструє, що пиво лишається актуальним,
церква може до цього долучитися – чудова комбінація!
Пиво продають навіть на Мальті і в Японії.
Однак більшу частину купують бари і ресторани
поблизу церкви святої Катерини.
Священик Жеремі особисто забирає пиво у броварні і розвозить.
Церковне пиво дуже популярне. У Брюсселі мешкає багато молоді з усього світу.
Мало хто з них ходить до церкви, але як вони ставляться до церковного пива?
Мені дуже подобається, трішки гіркувате, але водночас солодке і чудового кольору.
Я не дуже релігійний, але мені байдуже, що це пиво робить церква, як на мене це навіть круто!
Гроші від продажу "Санкт Кат" повністю йдуть
на необхідні ремонтні роботи будівлі.
Купити пиво можна навіть після недільної служби в церкві.
Багато парафіян беруть одразу кілька пляшок з собою.